[Musique]
chaque fois que nous laissons une
sorcière libre d'agir
le malin à 3 son pouvoir ce retour est
bien ici ma petite fille
obliger à sociale
les sorcières cesseront d'exister
lorsque vous cesserez de les mener au
bûcher je ne t'ai pas failli tu dis pour
que tu t'es révolte contre ton père
c'est elle
[Applaudissements]
lorànt deutsch
des n'ai pas peur
justement nous t'attendions
vous vous demandez sans doute qu'il nous
sommes
voilà nous sommes votre famille parce
que nous représentons pour eux le plus
terrible des dangers nous possédons tout
une force d'user
il suffit de découvrir ce que c'est et
de ne pas en avoir peur
[Musique]
nous découvrez ci s'en serait fini de
[Applaudissements]
le premier le plus grand des pouvoirs
et la connaissance de tous
[Musique]
les événements terribles sont sur le
point de tenir s'ils nous découvre ici
s'en sera fini de nous les sorcières que
tu te donne tant de peine à défendre
nous sommes prêts à les traquer une à
une jusqu'à ce que nous les aimons tout
déloger de leur tanière
je veux qu'ils ne restent pas mamie sol
il rafle des femmes
ils les enlèvent une à une sans
distinction
depuis corps est ce que d'autres gros
essayer de sauver des femmes je pensais
que c'était cela notre mission oui tu
connais pas ce que vous faites
objet d'attention
obama
nos ennemis se prépare à tout nous
détruire à nous effacés de la surface de
la terre
courez voir et il ya le moindre truc qui
me sifflent
ok je ne peux pas te parler
je suis occupé je travaille autour du
costume presque à les ouvrir
amy tu vas bien le chat le chat
[Musique]
m6 il a bousculé salon je suis là par
hasard couillon la teinte est rassuré
parce que sinon je te rejoins mexicaine
du coin pour qu'ils transforment en
attaque aussi
oh
white america
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
de taille d'une carte
si la france
quite à fait serein chicken est candidat
à quoi la présidentielle mais j'ai payé
moi j'étais en taule
j'ai été moi même chez les flics une 0
enrichissement personnel
t'as rien à aucune force n'a aucun
soutien
on parle quand même d'occuper la même
fonction que françois mitterrand où le
général de gaulle alors inévitablement
on sent tout petit baron noir pour
vaincre faillir too crois que le petit
promu adjudant le grand penseur il parle
du poste du matin au soir mes pulls mais
plus de place l'extrême droite cesse
d'être extrêmes virage à gauche
virage à droite remonter très haut comme
ça
c'est magistral on dirait du riz tard
en plus raffinée que je comptais sur la
clé seyrig ma jeunesse j'ai jamais ça y
est c'est mon heure à moi mais ça vient
faire [ __ ] partent à la guerre sans
s'assurer qu'on a fait on a 80 députés
et une grosse [ __ ] la mienne magnifique
c'est amplement suffisant pour partir à
la guerre
je te tuerais pour gagner une
présidentielle il faut savoir sentir le
parfum du punk et céline ya d'autres
sujets vous voyez apparaître derrière
moi le fait qu'on nous allons découvrir
nos premières estimations dans
maintenant quelques secondes voici donc
les résultats du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle damien jussiê
créations originales barreaux noirs
saison 3 bientôt et seulement sur canal+
[Musique]
ce
elle les profs qu'on ait personne pour
vous dire si vous allez réussir votre
vie ou pas moi j'en sais rien ce que
vous allez dans dix ans
je crois qu'à pas vraiment je vais
commencer une liste de ce que je veux
réaliser moi jamais [ __ ] mais moi
c'est des fous moi p g j'ai juste peur
de ne pas réussir ce que j'entreprends
je fasse parce qu'on n'a pas tous un
talent on n a pas envie de pleurer quand
tu vois ta tête parmi de pleurer c'est
un mec quand je stresse et j'arrive plus
à rien donc si tu veux car ça que j'ai
zéro à cause de toi ça va aller au
franchement c'est la pire année de ma
vie et que je serai encore plus au lycée
pu perdre un peu de poids
mais la rigueur par téléphone et même
les filles à l'envié c'est irrespectueux
pour toi c'est quel âge l'âge idéal pour
cent pour la première fois non parce que
j'aimerais dire vous allez devoir
réfléchir aux choix qui va être le vote
je pense que je suis plus attiré par les
personnes un joueur de mieux comprendre
les choses
dans cette période si douloureuse dans
notre pays la france est forte elle se
lève toujours
disons que ça ne te laisse aux jusqu'à
ce que je vais faire [ __ ] on s'en fout
tu vas partir à paris moi je vais partir
assure limoges tu sais quand on se
reverra meura gras changer toutefois
j'ai angoissant je trouve le futur
engrais
et
[Musique]
papillon attacafa je suis né avec une
paralysie
ça me dérange pas pour dessiner des
mangas je peux voir votre travail
[Musique]
je trouve vos personnages intéressants
et j'adore l'histoire
à conseiller un dessinateur de se servir
de son expérience c'est ça qui vous
manquent
alors bonne chance
[Musique]
tu vas comme ça va tu dessines label
tél
tu reviens à quelle heure ce soir je ne
vais pas trop tard tu sors très souvent
tu te rends compte que tu peux pas de
défendre et qui te faisait attaquer ya
plein de gens bizarres tue personne
s'intéresse à moi
quelqu'un en police des ça y est très
lente en quittant oui c'est peut-être
mon père des idées et le voir la patte
d'un f notre guy romande et au tessin
tu peux rien faire ça moi rien notre moi
comment tu fais tu aurais 37 compte ses
sous
second rouge pas respirer
[Musique]
ces contacts que c'est ça moi
oui oui bonjour madame valberg
excusez moi le boulet que je mon nom
fait c'était au sujet de valbert but n
est pas facile facile aux cigarettes ce
sont des light pro bowl et c'est calme a
déjà envoyé trois chauffeurs
ah bon vous allez m'aider à changer dès
demain mademoiselle valberg du chauffeur
je suis pas là pour changer votre salon
du raid m'expliquer ce qu'on vient de
faire mais n'étaient pas montés mes
valises
je n'ai pas porté mes affaires comme
juste dire merci et bonne soirée
pourquoi vous avez raconté arsenic et
voulait que ce soit absolument moi qui
vous conduisent et vous pourquoi vous
êtes revenu parce que j'ai pas le choix
une petite fille de 10 ans et si je la
garde partagée bas ce travail sans quoi
ça pue la colle à papier plein vous
savez les aldéhydes un serveuse elle
porte j'adore et vous connaissez la
recette de tous les parfums comme ça moi
qui l'écrit mais sa période de gloire à
l'époque on lui déroule et des ponts
d'or pour qu'elles signalent parfois ça
vous fait penser à quoi je sais pas vous
êtes vous confiant ça peut faire faire
du parfum me mettre derrière pour vous
n'aurez pas quelqu'un dont c'est le
métier parce que vous êtes doué
guillaume
le serbe avait pas un seul instant vous
avez levé la tête pour la regarder mais
ils n'ont pas qu'une odeur si vous
n'êtes même pas capable de lire de mots
juste deux mots merci saint pry
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un coup d'essai
radioactivité
c'est ce qu'a vu coco comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]